DEREK DOWNEY: Hi,
I'm Derek Downey,
a Developer Advocate at Google.
I am currently working
on developing a banking
application that leverages
Cloud Spanner for its ability
to seamlessly scale
without losing
strong external consistency.
In my last video, I
highlighted how simple
it was to get started
working with the Spanner
Emulator running
on my own device
to run my basic banking
app that's in development.
Now, I want to connect to
a real Spanner instance
so it can be used for
development by my team.
In this video, I will dig deeper
into what a Spanner instance is
and the different
options available
when creating an instance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Like all other Google
Cloud products,
Spanner instances must be
created inside a project.
So my Spanner instance will be
created in my organization's
development project.
For Spanner, an instance
refers to an amount
of compute and storage capacity
that you get access to.
An instance will have
at least three replicas
created, depending on which
configuration you choose.
This means that Spanner provides
high availability by default.
Each instance can have
multiple databases,
depending on your needs.
For my banking application, I
will create a single database
for customers and
their transaction.
The cost of this
instance is determined
by how much compute capacity
I provision, how much storage
my database uses, how much
storage my backups use,
and finally, how much
network bandwidth I use.
As I get started on
this application,
the largest cost will come from
the compute capacity itself.
The compute capacity
cost is determined
by both the number of
nodes and the configuration
that I choose.
I should mention that
in Spanner, nodes
is the measurement of how
much compute capacity that
is provisioned for my instance.
This setting has no bearing
on how many replicas I get.
I will always get at
least three replicas.
Since I am just getting
started with this application,
a full node of compute
capacity is too much.
Luckily, I can go smaller
than a single node
by using processing
units instead.
1,000 processing units is the
equivalent compute capacity
of a single node in Spanner.
And I can provision these
in increments of 100.
So I will create my instance
with 100 processing units,
which gives me roughly
1/10 the compute
resources of a single
node at 1/10 the cost.
Besides sizing, the
other important factor
for creating a Spanner
instance is the configuration.
The configuration determines
how many replicas I get
and where they are located.
It also determines
the type of replicas
that are handled by Spanner.
And luckily, as a
developer, I don't
have to manage the replicas.
They are completely
managed by Spanner.
There are two types of
configurations in Spanner--
regional and multi-regional.
For regional
configurations, I would
get three read-write replicas
in the region I choose.
Read-write replicas participate
in votes to commit rights,
and these replicas can
also be promoted to leader
for high availability.
A regional configuration
is a good option
if my application
will be operating
within a single region.
I want to choose a region
where my application is located
to reduce request latency.
To achieve higher
availability, though, I
would consider a
multi-regional configuration.
These configurations
provide read-write replicas
in two regions, as well as
maintaining a witness replica
in a third region.
Witness replicas do
not contain any data,
but they do provide
votes for quorum.
Also, witness replicas can never
be promoted to become a leader.
Some configurations also
offer read-only replicas
in additional regions.
These replicas contain
a full copy of data
so that they can reduce read
latencies in that region.
However, they can never
be promoted as a leader,
and read-only replicas
don't participate
in voting to commit rights.
So they don't impact
write latency performance.
Multi-regional configurations
are a great way
to achieve the
highest availability
for your Spanner-backed
applications.
It's important that
applications are effectively
deployed in the
appropriate regions
to take full advantage
of the configuration.
You can get more information
on available Spanner
configurations from the
link in the description.
For my development
application, I'm
going to create a regional
configuration in US Central 1.
All right, so to
create my instance,
I provided a size
and a configuration.
All I need now is
to provide the name
and an optional description
for the instance.
Then I can create it.
Once the instance
is created, I will
need to update my
application to use it.
To connect to Spanner, I
will need the project ID
for the project that my
Spanner instance is located in.
I will also need
the instance ID.
I also need to
authenticate my machine
to be able to work with
the project resources.
I do this using
the gcloud command.
Now, in Intellij, I will
create a new data source
and point my new Spanner
instance using the project
and instance information.
The URL connection
string is different,
as it no longer points
to the Emulator.
And there-- it's connected.
Now I will need to
modify the application
code with the project
and instance information.
If I run my commands
to create the database,
it will create
the customer table
on the development Spanner
instance that I just created.
Now, we have our
banking application
using a real Spanner instance
instead of the Emulator.
My team can start
using it today.
My instance is a
regional configuration
with a small amount of compute
resources for our development
needs.
Choosing the right
configuration is important.
So I have provided
additional resources
on Spanner configurations
in the video description.
These resources
can help you decide
which configuration might be the
right one for your application.
In our next video,
I will dig deeper
into what database
options exist for Spanner.
In the meantime,
please let us know
if you have any questions
about Spanner instances,
costs, or configurations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]